(upbeat music)
♪ Yeah, okay it's Tea With GaryVee ♪
♪ Sip it empathy ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea With GaryVee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
- Good morning, everybody.
4-20 I know that's got
a lot of you fired up.
Super excited about today,
sorry, just posting something on the gram.
Good morning, good morning, good morning,
April 20, hope everybody's doing well,
I know we're in it,
the beards are growing out,
the excitement is building,
the anxiety is building,
we are now well into this global pandemic,
and I hope everybody's
families are healthy,
and I hope you're starting
to turn some of the angst
and curiosities and
concerns into optimism,
practicality, hope, humility.
I think the show has been unbelievable
and I've been very grateful
for everybody who's been tuning in.
So as a matter of fact, on that note,
if you could just take
a screenshot right now
either of the screen
you're watching a laptop
or a screenshot there and tweet it out,
Facebook it out or put
in your Instagram story
with the link to this episode right now
I'd like to bring in some new folks,
some new friends into the realm.
Let me say good morning to
some people in the comments,
Saggy karma what's good?
Rosa, Juarez Perez, how are you?
Mike Man, what's good?
Julie Higgins Yat Chuck, great to see you,
then Dane Baxter, Papi TV, Saeed, Jabbar,
what's good, my man it's great to see you.
Always great to see you,
man I root for you heavy,
Hanky Raps, Jeff Garbus, Linda Jr,
Mary Robinson, Tanya, and Travis Rogers.
Thank you all so much for being here,
really, really, really appreciate it.
Andrea, Erica Guarday,
Garret Glen, Ashley Gomez,
Chris Gareth, Flight
Winfield, good morning,
good morning, Sendal, Lizanne is fun.
All right, let's get into show Dustin,
Dustin get in here real
quick, Dustin not Justin.
- What's up.
- What's up is I think
you're becoming a viral hit,
and I'm happy for you.
I'm sure you've blown up in the BMX,
35-year-old look like 16-year-old,
are you starting to get some buzz Dustin?
Are you feeling it?
Are you getting like some DMs?
Shoot with me like I'm your friend.
Like, talk to me. Are you
getting a little buzz?
Are you getting a little action on socials
some DMS some love?
- Yeah, I mean definitely,
But it's, I mean mostly just people
that wanna be on the show.
- They don't love you.
- They're right hooking all day.
- Hey Natalie.
(speaks in foreign language)
- I'm good, I'm good.
- What's cooking?
- Lots of gratitude for being here.
- Happy to have you.
- So I had to like write out my questions
because I can't even form it.
I always watch your
content to find the answer,
I feel like I still can't
get the full clarity.
- Great that's what we're here for.
- Here's the backstory.
So I'm an actor, a
comedian, I do stand up,
I post on Tik Tok, I post on
Instagram, I post on YouTube.
Everything is incrementally
progressing, okay, great.
I can hear your voice being like,
just fucking be patient, just like fuck,
like, like, fuck, like, just like,
be patient with the
process, I hear it, okay?
We're going in a positive direction great,
but sometimes I feel lost
like I'll watch Chappelle do stand up,
and I'm like, if I only did
stand up, I would kill it.
And then I'm like, if I only did Tik Tok,
I'd have 10 million followers.
And so, I know I've heard you say
before that doing things in waves is okay,
like it's okay to go hard with content
and then it's okay to
go hard with stand up
and shut everything off,
that's tough for me doing stuff in waves,
I don't know if I should
shut something off,
and then I'm constantly
trying to find the intertwine,
like I know you have pillar content,
So I could film everything
and then divide it out,
it's just a lot.
And so every morning I'm like,
what's the most important
thing I can get done today?
And sometimes I'm like, and
then I get hit with an audition,
and then they'll shut everything off,
like, phones off everything.
And I'll go away for like
three days, memorize the lines.
So and then I wanna start
a product right now,
so...
- It's good.
All right, let's break it down.
Let me ask you a question,
And it can change and
I'm sure it has changed
as your career's evolved,
but right now what is the ultimate?
- Long term goal is and I don't know
if it's gonna become
extinct, but movies TV show,
like I wanna be known as the
greatest character actress,
like, wow, she's like our
generation's Meryl Streep,
she can transform into
character, she can tell stories.
So I know that's my
responsibility to put that on--
- No, no, you know what's funny,
I'm gonna throw some curve balls at you
because I think what you're
giving me is enough context
to know that you know,
a lot of my answers,
so what I'm trying to think about is,
back to the point of why I
think this show is working,
is have more time to go
deeper or more contextual.
So a couple things,
how much time or energy
do you spend on management
or agents?
- All day every day?
I mean you mean finding representation
or working with them?
- Both.
- Yeah, it's a lot of every day
and I have an Excel
spreadsheet of like producers
I wanna work with and like,
you know, I'm working--
- What about management and agents?
Do you have one?
- Yeah.
- And, like not to put them on blast,
one of the things that's
been very obvious to me,
is the serendipity of
the relationship graph,
so if your goal is to be Meryl Streep,
or have a real true acting career, right?
Yes, I do believe a singular Tik Tok,
I mean, look at look at King Bach,
he's like, slowly but surely, right?
He's been able to do it,
he came from vine, and here he is.
I turn on Netflix, and
he's in the movies, right?
Like there he is,
the couple things, where do you live?
- LA, I'm in New York right now,
but I like go back and forth.
- Got it.
So one thing I would
spend a ton of time on
is content strategy on Tik Tok
around the children of the
power agents in Hollywood.
- Okay, so telling stories that--
- Nope, I'm going in very narrow for you.
I would find out who the 50
biggest agents in Hollywood are,
which is super easy,
and I would literally try to find out
if their sons and daughters
are on social media,
like I'm talking fucking like
Kojak Sherlock Holmes shit.
And would literally
tag them in my content.
- Tag their kids?
- Yep.
- GaryVee is telling me
to tag the executive kids
and like, right TV executives.
- Yep.
- And be like, want to do a Tik Tok, duet?
- Nope, tagging.
You know how that works,
they're just gonna see it.
- Okay, they're not gonna be like,
"Dad, she just twerked, eew."
No, I don't do that.
- No, it's really interesting.
I know it seems like, you know,
again, like really listening to this call,
like, you know, a lot
of things I believe in,
do I believe a single viral
epic Tik Tok can get you there?
I do, do I think that
that takes a lot of output
and a lot of serendipity
and a lot of things?
Like, I'll give you a good example.
I always felt like social
media was a good place
for me to create top of the funnel brand,
I spent eight years
saying no to everything,
and then Planet the Apps came
Apple's first original show,
Gwyneth Paltrow, WillIam,
Jessica Alba, the other judges,
it's a good elevation for me
in my domain expertise of
making investments in apps,
it's Apple's first show,
I finally make the jump,
I commit to that time and then they decide
to not do what they just did,
which is what I thought
they were gonna do,
they decided to distribute
it to Apple Music,
and four and a half people saw it.
Thank you, if that got
distributed through Netflix,
or Apple TV's new version,
or even Amazon Prime or Hulu,
that would have worked for me
so I have tons of strategy,
gave all the stats and
there's so much serendipity
that goes into that game,
but then we control our
Tic Tok Instagram game,
so a couple things that I actually think
there's two parallel
paths, the two opposites,
you go super high, and
you try to truly penetrate
the awareness graph of the 50,000 guys
who run Hollywood from the agent side,
and then you do what you're doing
which you do well is creative at scale
across all the relevant platforms,
because those are actually the two ways
people get to become
who you want to become.
- Right, I'm like,
pulled in the traditional
and the social world, but
then I'll have Instagram--
- And Mark Sadlowski saying like,
it's the first time I
don't like what Gary says,
and I totally get it.
Like, I understand that
a lot of people are like,
that seems off creepy or wrong.
But here's my point of view,
my point of view very simply is,
people are on these platforms for content,
you're trying to bring
awareness to somebody,
you can DM them,
you can send them a nice
link email on LinkedIn,
you can send a letter, you
can send a gift basket.
I genuinely believe that tagging,
people that are influencers
of the influencer,
whether that's admins,
whether that's best friends,
whether that's children.
If you're making a age appropriate video,
everyone's like, "Oh, a 14-year-old."
14-year-olds fucking
hear more shit in school
than every single adult I know every day,
people living in a naive
world and so I'm empathetic
and understand people's
point of view on that,
but I'm completely convinced
that building awareness
towards children or influencers or admins
leads to opportunity and
it's nothing negative,
I just believe that to be true.
- Yeah, I'm never somebody
who's scared to reach out cold
and, you know, I have producers
that follow me on Instagram,
I feel a lot of pressure every time I post
I got big people follow me big execs,
I mean, like I can't
name names but top dogs,
so I feel a lot of pressure
and then I know I need
to get my quality up,
I know you've talked to people
about not obsessing about quality,
but if I see myself as an actress,
it does need to be top notch sound.
Once in a while, not every video.
- Listen, I'm with you,
I'm genuinely not against it,
I'm against it when
people can't afford it,
or use it as an excuse not to make.
- Yeah, but I think I
need to kick my game up,
and I think there is the
occasional iPhone video great.
- I think that real talent evaluators
are able to see through production value.
And I would argue that
the best talent evaluators
in Hollywood often need the ability
to be able to dream it versus seeing it,
so let me give an example.
This Thursday's the NFL Draft,
a lot of kids are gonna get drafted,
who actually play in small schools
because the GM's dream that
if they played in big school,
they would have been even better
because they would have better
weight rooms, better coaches,
so I actually feel like a
lot of the Hollywood types
actually overlook and skip over people
with high production on
YouTube and Tick Tok,
because it shows them
exactly who they are,
and they dismiss it
because it's still a
grade below Hollywood,
but when they see it in
iPhone, or kind of like,
whatever they dream like,
oh, I see that star,
I can polish that star, it's ego.
- Totally, people wanna discover me.
I mean, I've so many people--
- But stick with me here of course that,
but like stick with me,
because I don't want
you to lose this point.
The reason lower quality content
has value is they dream up,
Oh, if I put production value behind her,
she can crush, something to keep in mind.
I see--
- I got it, I got it.
And then doing stuff in waves,
just like fuck it if you have
to do stand up for two weeks--
- Look now, I think people need to do
what comes natural to them,
because I think they need a lot of output
and hard work to actually get there.
So to me, you know if waves work great,
if you need to go hardcore in
something for six months great
if you do helter skelter every day great,
I wanna give a lot of
different scenarios to people
so they can find their way.
- Got it.
- Awesome.
Now give a shout out to your account
so people can follow you.
- Everything is Natalie
Friedman on Instagram,
Tik Tok, YouTube Friedman
is spelt like fried man.
- I love it, good luck.
- Thank you so much, appreciate you, bye.
- All right, big shout
out to everybody here.
By the way, somebody said
something about the IRS,
Gary, what can I get the IRS,
gets their people's money, so got it.
Well, people have been
getting their money,
because the amount of stuff
being bought on eCommerce
last week is ludicrous as
stimulus checks have hit
and I'm so fucking angry, fuck man.
Like literally people get
their 1200 dollar check or more
and they fucking spend
it immediately, fuck.
All my eCommerce friends are like,
"We're exploding this week."
and I'm like, "What the fuck?"
Literally hundreds of them,
and I'm like, holy shit
people are actually
taking the stimulus check
and buying dumb fucking shit.
Anyway, Dustin keep going.
- Hey, how's it going, Gary?
- It's going well William, do
you by Bill or William or--
- William is great man.
So just a little background
on me, I'm an actor as well,
probably best known for playing
the red Power Ranger on TV,
and I actually took a lot away
from the conversation you just had,
- I love that.
- Writing down notes like crazy.
- What most hit you, William?
- The thing you said at the
end about you need to do
what comes natural to you
because there's so much output
necessary to achieve anything--
- Struck right?
- Yeah, it completely struck.
- People create friction.
Oh, I need to do it like Gary
or I need to do like William,
they create friction.
You know, like, I'd love to be Sam Donald,
there's no throwing footballs outside
that are gonna get me there.
People create friction,
and I'm trying to create,
just a stream of pass throughs
because the output is the variable.
- Yeah, just completely following through.
Like I think about that where,
there's not really any rules
where people will say that
they'll follow one person's
content or this person's content
and they'll use a certain approach,
but basically, my question for you was,
so earlier on life was very simple for me,
I was like this economic
student who dropped out
to pursue acting and I
got maniacal about acting,
and I did a whole lot in one year,
but then, I felt this thing
inside where I was like,
this isn't moving fast enough for me,
there's so much more I can do,
I have time on my hands,
I've got potential,
so I started an online
fitness coaching business,
I wrote two books, and I just
started building other things
built my YouTube, built a podcast
when I got into your content, I was like,
ooh, time to get on every platform.
So I built up this podcast,
I started, you know, doing
the pillar content strategy,
road, put a lot out.
And I got myself to a point now where,
I've always liked biting
off more than I can chew,
but I've gotten myself to a
point now where it's like,
there are so many plates
spinning everyday.
- Do you have the humility
to shut things down
and have perceived losses?
- I don't feel like
like I'm at a point yet
where I need to shut it down,
I just don't know how to
prioritize all of it yet.
- That's an excuse.
What I mean by that is
prioritization comes in the thing
that needs it the most,
it's like children.
If you have four children,
you need to prioritize
the child that's most
struggling at that moment.
Prioritization's easy,
humility to shut down
something down is hard.
- Then I probably like the humility.
- It makes sense.
Notice how I go to something
that's not so obvious,
but it's the fucking answer, humility.
Humility to say,
people with a lot of ambition and energy,
whether they are gabbers
like me and just talk shit,
like, "Everything's gonna be humongous."
Or if they're quiet, but
they still have five to seven
people that they value very
much knowing what they're up to.
Almost everybody right now is doing things
that they don't wanna be doing,
because they don't have the
humility to take the micro loss.
- Okay, I can think of
a few things like that--
- Of course, like immediately right?
Like this is how humans work,
like immediately I'm talking you're like,
"Yeah, fuck the podcast.
"Like it's taking too much time.
"People are listening who gives a fuck?"
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I do it all pro, I do it all the time.
I'm working on action figures right now,
I've been trying to launch a beanie brand
for like four years,
I take the losses, I
micro lose all the time,
just constantly, but most
people don't have the humility.
And I think humility has to
be one of the great emerging,
let me just go actually very simple,
if my audience doesn't
quadruple down on humility,
post COVID, it would be a
real missed opportunity.
Because I'm very passionate about it,
I communicate it, I
articulate well, you know,
here we are, for you brother William
and a lot of other people
watching right now,
literally I genuinely
believe in the next week,
like 100 people right now
just decided to drop something
that's gonna completely open them up.
People are talking about prioritizing,
because they don't have the humility
to drop three things they already know,
they just need the encouragement,
and the courage and the shield,
they need this video to point to,
to be like, "Well, GaryVee said."
By the way, my great love of my life,
is being the shield that allows people
to do things that make them happy.
I want people to point to me,
I want kids to point their parents to me,
I want parents to point their kids to me,
I want somebody who stops
doing their podcasts
and their mom makes a snarky comments
see, you always fucking
fail to show this video
and say, fuck you, mom.
You know what I mean?
Like, I want that.
- Well, part of the mindset
for me behind it is like,
and this comes from the past
with weight training and sports
and stuff like that is that,
I know what that pressure does to me.
- Do you like it?
- Yeah, I like it and I feel like
having that weight on
my shoulders sometimes--
- I do too.
Let me tell you the
difference between you and I.
I don't have this question.
- That's why I'm on this show.
- What I mean by that though is,
I want you to figure out
if you've made the ideology
within yourself that
you've created an ideology
that you like it, or do
you actually like it?
It's a very important point brother,
because if you're asking
it, if you're sitting on it,
you may not like it as much as you think.
- I like it,
but I don't wanna drop
the ball on anything,
that's the way that I feel.
I feel like I need to follow through--
- You have to, if you're
a juggler, you drop balls.
- Okay, that makes sense.
- I'm telling you right
now it's fucking humility.
I love spinning 49 plates
and watching 13 crash,
because it keeps me in a learning mindset,
and I don't give a fuck
if the people who are
watching me spin the plate
laugh at me when I drop the plate,
because I look at them and ask them,
"Don't worry about my plates,
"how many plates are
you fucking spinning?"
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay, that makes sense to me,
that makes sense to me.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's humility, I'm telling you.
- Do you ever drop the
plate on so many things,
and then you just keep
piling more plates on it--
- Yes.
- Maybe I should just focus on the plates
that I have spinning.
- Always.
I hope you're not dwelling on the plate
that broke it fucking broke.
- No, I honestly don't dwell
like I don't dwell at all.
I totally hear you on that.
I just feel an obligation to
the people that I work with
in a lot of different things
to pull through for them--
- You can pull through for
them in different ways,
like if you have to drop that thing,
you can hire two of them
on the thing that's working
or help them get another,
like we don't have to go through layoffs,
I'm helping people get other jobs.
- Okay, I got you.
- You see what I mean?
You don't have to keep
them paid on that plate,
you can go help them
be in the fork business
or they can come and
help you spin the plate
that's actually fucking working.
- Yeah, I got you.
So just reallocate, move things around,
and keep moving forward.
- And a lot of times the person
that you're letting down,
you actually deep down know
that they're not good enough
and don't do what I did for a long time,
which is carry them out of compassion.
You know, what you wanna do
is set them up with candor
and give them another
opportunity somewhere else.
That was a real shortcoming of mine,
I carried dead weight for years, decades,
because I am a nice person,
but ultimately, I created
a resent relationship
with that individual and
they weren't growing with me,
so I've learned only recently
in the last half decade
that it is okay to let people go,
especially if you're willing
to help them post you.
- Yeah, okay, I got you.
I've got one little follow up question.
- Real fast.
- I'm sure that you got
people that do this for you,
but in terms of your whole game plan,
do you create like a weekly
schedule or a daily schedule?
Or do you do you just
roll with the punches?
- I'm admin out, I have three admins
and every minute I mean, literally,
if you looked at my calendar right now,
every minute of my day is,
I'm literally booked right now,
every minute no gaps until 9 p.m.
I have no I I've literally no
idea what the fuck I'm doing,
Google Calendar tells me every second.
It's all happening in
flow with infrastructure,
and that's how I'm bouncing
from so many things.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay, that makes sense.
- Awesome.
- You've helped me out a
ton, thank you brother.
- You got it William, take care.
All right, that was some good shit.
You know what team, let's let's
chop that up for LinkedIn.
Let's get that into LinkedIn,
let's get them into Rogoff's hands
see how he wants to position it,
but that felt very operational.
I feel like there's some LinkedIn peeps
that can get some real value from that.
Let's keep it going.
Brendan Zhang.
- Hey Gary, what's up man?
- What's good brother.
- I'm super, super happy to be here,
just wanna say that first.
- Thank you.
- So can I give you a
little bit of context first?
- Please.
- Alright, so I discovered you about
two to three years ago in high school,
I've always loved your
energy, enthusiasm and passion
and your approach to everything.
- Thank you.
- I find your advice, super easy to apply
and it was immediate help me
in my self improvement journey.
- That's awesome, thank you.
- So, obviously, as you
probably know, like,
I've heard a lot from you
over the past few years,
and the thing that's helped me the most
and what I actually
want to talk about today
is creating accessibility
to where I wanna be
via like the Instagram DM.
And so I'm a really big sports
fan, and I'm super interested
in like the business side of social media,
so over the summer, I had DM'd like,
a lot of accounts like, I'm
talking like Sports Center,
House of Highlights, Bleacher Report.
And then, you know, just
companies like Nike,
Adidas and Puma and stuff like
individual athletes as well.
And I had DM'd this one
company called Overtime,
have you heard of it?
- I've heard of everything.
- Okay.
So yeah, I had DM'd this--
- That was so funny.
Obviously, I haven't heard of everything,
but I'm on my shit, of course,
I know what overtime is.
Keep going.
- Okay, yeah.
So I had DM'd this one
company called Overtime,
I really like the mission behind it
and also the creativity of their content.
And you know, with all these DMs like,
I can't remember when
I heard you say this,
but I had like made a
decision over the summer
to DM everybody,
and I had like zero expectations
with any of it right?
I would just, you know,
send it and forget about it.
And I'll fast forward four to five months,
I'm literally chilling in my dorm,
I go to the University
of Minnesota, by the way.
I'm literally just chilling in my dorm,
like I'm about to take a nap
like my roommate James can attest to this,
it's like 4 p.m I'm about to take a nap,
I get this random text message like, "Hey,
"it's Thomas from Overtime,
"you wanna film this
basketball game tonight?"
And I'm like super hesitant,
but I eventually you
know, just say fuck it,
because I don't know the place at all.
So like, I was hesitant at first,
but then I end up going to
film this basketball game
and like long story short,
it's like the best experience
that I've ever dreamed about,
I mean I was like a big
consumer of Overtime's content
beforehand, so like I knew
like a lot about their brand,
and I knew what type of videos they made,
so I'm like, you know, a
super big basketball guy.
So like, you know, the high school dynamic
and like the top athletes that come out,
like that was a super
cool environment for me.
- I love it and..
- Yeah.
It was the best job ever.
So, okay, my question is like,
I'd say in the past,
like four or five months,
I've been like, super
successful and leveraging,
like, you know, my position over time
is truly like a blessing
to be able to work there,
and I've been able to leverage it like,
I've actually gotten
responses from Zaire Wade,
who's Dwyane Wade son,
and actually Mikey Williams as well,
I don't know if you've heard of him,
- I don't know if I've heard of him.
- I've filmed like top athletes
and I've been able to like leverage this,
and to like get replies from other people,
and I feel like--
- So Brendan, what's the question
before my audience destroys you.
- So I feel like I'm on
the verge of something
and I'm just like I don't really
know what to do from there.
- Well what do you want to do?
- Well like ideally like eventually
I want to you know work
for like an NBA team,
I'm super into like the
sports business industry
and I feel like I'm on
the verge of something
with like the DMs and stuff,
but I don't really know
what to do from there.
- Just looking at my
conversations with Mikey Williams
trying to figure out when I
first hit him up January 2018.
You're on your way,
just keep networking
that's how you got here.
I mean, the biggest question by far
is what the fuck are you
doing napping at 4 p.m?
- It's just like, I just
came back from my classes--
- I don't give a fuck,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
All right, listen, I think you
keep doing what you're doing,
as you're getting connected with Mikey,
with Anthony, with young
with all these kids
that keep coming up the Israeli kid,
that tall lanky kid, you're in the culture
you know exactly what's happening.
Keep networking, keep bringing
value, keeping patient,
try to make content for people,
keep putting out karma,
you're so fucking young.
You should not go in for any ask or kill,
all these people are trying
to latch on to brawny,
like you know what's going on,
they're all trying to get something.
You don't get, you give, you
give, you give, you give,
I promise you, you'll be there.
Because if you DM a coach,
DM Erik Spoelstra and be
like you were a film guy,
and you're now the coach,
let me fucking do film
for you on the, you know,
16-year-olds right now,
then he'll be like,
"We're not interested in
that but my draft guy is."
What you already did you have to do again,
just follow the blueprint.
- Okay, yeah, that makes sense.
Also, I have like a secondary question.
So you talked about, creating value
and like giving, giving, giving,
is like something that I
need to keep doing right?
And so like, considering
like where I'm at right now,
what does giving really
look like in terms of--
- Ask people.
- Okay, so asking is like the same as--
- You got the leverage to your point,
well asking and then
giving what people want
versus giving what you
perceive is the answer.
I just answered your question,
like, well, what do I give?
I'm like easy, ask Winston what he wants.
Be like, "Yo, I fuck with your game,
"Coach, I love the way you."
You know what you do, map
every G League head coach,
and then DM them, you're gonna still have
the leverage of the logo
that's on your fucking chest,
and you're gonna say, "Yo,
what can I do for you?
"I'm hungry."
- Alright.
- Good, talk to them.
- Awesome, Gary thank you so much.
- You got it Brendan, take care Brendan,
It's fun, that is right,
SS give, give give.
People wanna give what they wanna give,
which is not giving it's 99% of time
manipulation to set up
what they actually want.
People wanna give me shit all the time
that I don't want, because
they want something from me.
Understand?
Let's keep it going.
Juju.
- GaryVee.
- What's good?
- What's up so funny yesterday
I was just presenting
a new project that we're
rolling out on zoom call,
and I present one of your
videos to sell the product,
telling people to become a
digital mayor of their hometown.
I'm like, "Look, GaryVee is saying this,
"you gotta jump on this product,
"because that's exactly
what our product does,
"and we gotta be the next Zillow."
So stay tuned for that, Gary,
I know if I present that to you
you're gonna buy everything,
now we'll talk later.
- Can't wait.
- But my question to you is,
my bestie and I, Amanda,
I know she's watching this
because I told her,
- What's good Amanda.
we just started our new
nonprofit organization
called The Hope for Tomorrow.
We help children in our local
community in fields of art,
music and dance, we want to support them
and eventually we want to have a center
where kids can come and be mentored
not in just those fields,
but also have lawyers,
they'll be able to help
them with contract.
You know, kids get taken advantage
of all the time in the music industry,
in the entertainment industry,
and we want to be able
to be there for them,
you know, Gary, and I've been going ham,
and I understand that
she had to pass an exam,
and I just kept taking action
because I'm the type of person
that if I don't take
action, and if I cool down,
I cool down for real, you know,
if I sit down to watch a movie,
I'm gonna take a nap so I
don't sit down to watch movies,
I keep going, I gotta
keep the momentum going.
But, you know from setting up
as a nonprofit with
Facebook and everything,
this stuff is hard, but I understood,
but one thing that I
told her that I was doing
was putting the business plan together,
and she said, "Hey, that's my field now,
"that's what I'm going to school for.
"I have a mentor for them,
we can ask her for help."
And I said, "Well, I kinda have a template
"that I'm going by, I would
kinda like to stick to that."
But then I'm the type of person
that I always think a little bit more.
So I started thinking like,
hey, I got so much on my plate,
maybe I should let her handle this,
this is a very new thing.
You know, maybe she'll be
better, she already has a mentor.
So I gave her that task,
Gary, it's been four months.
I'm sorry, it's been a month, four weeks,
and I don't have a business plan.
And I've asked, "Hey,
"what's going on with the business plan?
"Do you need any help?
"Is there anything I can do?
"Are you not comfortable with it?"
- What's the business plan for?
I understand where you're
going and if she's watching,
look four weeks is wildly inappropriate
to deliver something in a partnership,
especially when your partner's Juju
with the ears and fucking high energy,
like that's gonna create friction.
My bigger question is, the fuck
do need a business plan for?
- Well, here's the thing
Gary, we need a business plan
because we're going to
need people to donate.
- I see.
- So in order to have people to donate,
we need to be able to tell
them, here's what we doing,
this is what we're--
- That's not a business plan,
that's a communications plan,
that's a strategy,
- Yeah, that's exactly, I mean
some sort of template here,
this is what we need, you know.
- Hold on, hold on, let's say you and her
made the best fucking deck of all time,
you're gonna present that
to high net worth people
and want them to donate?
- Yeah, eventually.
- I'm not critiquing I'm
actually trying to understand
what you're trying to do, one more time,
I think you're not making a business plan,
I think you're making a
presentation to raise capital?
Is that true?
I'm asking.
- Well, that's included in it, you know,
because within the business plan,
we will also have our mission,
which we already have,
we just have everything
compacted in one, you know?
- I understand no matter
what word you or I use,
I'm trying to understand
what the purpose of it is.
So, you're gonna present that to whom,
with the hope of what?
- Well, number one, Gary,
I want to make sure that everybody
that comes into the organization with us,
they know exactly what our goals are--
- Your goal is to build an
ecosystem to help the kids
in your area to not get
screwed by Hollywood,
you could type that out.
- Well, not just that, and we have that.
And we have that but, for example,
we are going to have events,
how are we going to raise
capital for those events?
Who are we going to partner with?
- People don't invest in decks,
people invest in people Juju.
- If we were to have a nonprofit,
and you want everybody
to be on the same page,
and you want people to know,
here's where GaryVee
Foundation is gonna be
within the next five to 10 years--
- I would make videos and post
them and leave it at that.
- Gotcha.
- But that's not where we're going,
where I'm going is somewhere
a little bit different,
which is people value process
and checking the box of certain things
versus what the strategy is needed
to actually make it happen.
Instead of making that deck,
I wish you guys had made a video
interviewing all these kids on zoom,
and put it out on Facebook
groups in your local community,
because you would have
built more awareness
for what you're actually doing.
- Well, that's our plan.
And that's what we want to do
with the business plan is
to have all of that so--
- But that definitely doesn't
take four fucking weeks
for your friend to make the plan--
- That's my point,
well my whole question to you is,
how can we ask a business
partner you know,
or somebody that works with you,
that "Hey, I need this,
whatever you come up with,
"just present it to me
so we can work together
"and really see where we going
"because we need to
have like, for example,
"the video of the kids."
That's something we wanna do.
I'm all over social media, I love video,
I love interviewing people.
You know, that's one of the
things that we wanna do,
but I'm the type of
person that I want a list
to make sure where we're going
so we can check everything off--
- Making a list of where you're going,
takes four fucking seconds Juju.
- That's what I'm saying Gary.
- So write it down.
I'll be honest, I love you,
your energy is off the charts,
but I mean, like I'm
talking with love right now,
like write down nine
things on a piece of paper,
there's your plan.
- She'll lie like,
hey, you know, whatever, that's my point.
- Juju it's nine things, I just did it.
We just did it on Tea with GaryVee.
You're trying to do this
for kids in the local area,
it sounds like you need money,
which is ludicrous of a
strategy to start a nonprofit
during this time when nobody has money,
all the money's gone.
- The point is not to make
money right now, the point is--
- You told me you're trying to--
- And get the word out there, so--
- It's never gonna be about making money,
you started a nonprofit, you said to me
that you needed to raise
money to get this going.
Nobody's gonna give you a check.
- Well, I don't care,
I'm making my own check,
and I'll put in my own money, that's--
- Then why the fuck are
you spending four weeks
waiting for a deck for a
presentation to get money?
- That's my point, how do I--
- My point is what are you talking about?
Like in a good way.
- That to my best friend and
that hurt her feelings like,
hey, I've been waiting for four weeks,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, I just wanna be
able to communicate that
to her without hurting her feelings--
- Say I love you with all my heart,
with all my heart, are you okay?
I love you, are you okay?
It shouldn't take four weeks for you
to put nine things down
on a piece of paper.
Let's just do it right now over a Coco.
Juju you're spending time and
energy to make a presentation
to get people to give you donations
to have startup capital
for this nonprofit.
Starting a nonprofit
during a global pandemic,
when we lost 22 million jobs in four weeks
is a real stretch.
Like who are you going to
and how much money are trying to raise?
- We had already started
before all of this,
it's been a year and
it's a crazy story, Gary,
because we had a different partner,
we had a president that
really wasn't doing anything,
and just myself and Amanda,
were doing everything,
and we decided just to you know
what, let's just embrace it,
and let's just go in.
- Why don't you start a
zoom and a Google Hangouts
and just invite kids in
and just ask people to come
and educate them?
Why don't you take the form of the mission
into a digital three platform
that can help lots of kids,
instead of having to
put it in this container
of a nonprofit and a center.
The YMCA worked in 1972, the
fucking world is different now.
- I'm taking notes.
- Juju people get emotional
about the container
that they use or the vehicle
they use to create the mission.
And I keep reminding people in business
and nonprofit and politics and everything,
it's not about the vehicle,
don't be romantic about the vehicle,
don't make an ideology that
you're gonna have this beautiful center,
the center's there to help kids,
help kids for free on the internet,
make Tic Toks that help kids now,
I help kids for free
in my fucking underwear
at two o'clock in the
morning by making content.
- Powerful, that's sure.
- I'm glad you picked up on that.
- Creating a platform to help kids that--
- That's right, I'm glad
you picked up on that.
And I get it we grew up in,
you start to visualize
something with a purpose,
but like fuck, like if the
purpose is to help kids,
this year that you've spent
with a fucked up president
and your best friend going through,
pass some tests it sounded like,
and then four weeks like, you could have
fucking already impacted 8000 kids
on fucking free Tik Toks fucking lives.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Get off the romance of
how you're gonna do it
and get on the romance of what
you're trying to accomplish.
- That sure the vehicle
doesn't matter, you know?
- No, it doesn't.
And the vehicle you're
trying to do right now
is expensive during a time
where that's not practical.
- That's good.
- Good Juju, good luck.
Take care.
- Thank you so much, bye.
- That ended well, I'm excited about that.
Getting in it.
You know what's amazing about this show
is because I have more
time I can go deeper,
I'm not gonna cutting it off,
you know, before we get to it.
That conclusion, that'll
help Juju and her friend,
about a nonprofit because they don't need
to fucking build a center to
accomplish what they want.
I know there's a ton
of parallels right now
to a lot of people,
businesses and parenting.
One parent was like,
"I just want my kid to be happy."
By torturing them to be on the
lacrosse team and go to Yale?
What are you a fucking asshole?
Like come on, let's get smarter.
Focus on the goal, not your
ideology of the vehicle
to get to the goal.
Let's go.
- Kevin.
- Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- How are you doing?
- I'm well.
- I'm well, thanks.
That a prior comment is a great lead in.
I got a parenting question here for you.
- Please, please.
- I have a 16-year-old, I got four kids
and I actually have two dogs too
so don't be stressed if
you hear some barking
in the background.
- No worries.
- I've got a 16-year-old
son he's my oldest,
he is by all accounts
the traditional student,
does really well in school, straight A's,
does grade 8 standardized
tests all that sort of stuff.
If this were 20, 25 years ago,
when probably you and I were kids,
we'd be saying doctor, lawyer, you know.
- All that, yep.
- Going up for it.
My fear as a parent is that
he will always be a good student,
and he'll be good at whatever he does,
but he won't necessarily
love what he does.
How should I help him through that?
- First of all, I don't
know if this is gonna
come through I think it is actually.
Yep, I love you, I love you, Kevin.
No, really, I mean, it.
I just showed my goosebumps,
look, they're really coming in.
Like, I really, really love you
because your kids are
very lucky to have you.
That is an incredibly profound
and very, like, just noble question.
You know, I think it's about
education, like anything else.
I think just like the reverse of like
me trying to push my buddy
who like thinks his son
needs to go to play
lacrosse and this and that,
because lacrosse will get into Yale
as if Yale means anything,
his kid's not happy,
I know it the kid's DMing me.
So I think what you wanna do is
a lot of kids like that
have figured out a system,
they've figured out the school
system, and they feel safe,
which is why they're gonna
then take a job that's safe,
but they're not going to
be passionate, or on fire.
So you need to have that communication,
you know, really genuinely
treat him like an adult and say,
"Look, this is a potential."
Not "Son, I think this is exactly
"what's gonna happen to you."
But this is a potential thing
that might happen to you.
And is this where you're at?
What do you love?
Or you observe them and you pay attention
to things they do like outside of school,
does he show any interest
outside of school?
Did we lose Kev?
Nick excuse me, Dustin
I think we lost him.
Let's get him back.
Let's go next one and get him back.
Great question.
- Gary what's going on brother?
- What's good, bro?
- Hey, quick question,
quick backstory I guess.
I've been following you
for about five years
since the fuck Monday video,
scrolling on Facebook.
- Yes that--
- Oh my God, man.
It's seared into my head.
But quick that same story, went to college
first generation immigrant back 92
from Iraq family came here.
So watched the entire family
just work work work work work.
- Yeah, start from bottom.
- Oh my God.
- Was it a classic immigrant story,
where your parents and grandparents
or family members had these kind of jobs
in the old country but here
they had a fucking eat dirt?
- It was literally 92
they came in my parents,
uncle, grandparents, worked
in Greece for two years
got the paperwork came to US,
lived in my great uncle's home,
and just--
- Similar to my story wow.
- Dude yes.
So a lot of stores, you
know, corner stores,
restaurants, all the way up to ownership.
- And what did your dad do in
Iraq back in the 80s and 90s?
- They were just working
in the restaurants,
him and my mom, they had me at 21
and they had like 4 to 5 days
to decide to join the army
or flee the country so
they're like, we're gone.
- Go ahead bro, what can I do for you?
- Yeah, so the question is man,
I've watched the grind and I'm
running my own business now,
eCommerce drop shipping business
and a digital marketing agencies
literally based on all the
models that you've shown on
LinkedIn and so if your watch
and everything you do say it does work.
But the question I have right now
is my two business partners
they were mentors to me
they're both in their 50s I'm only 28,
and they tell me this all time,
Lazar you gotta you gotta
stop being a yes man
or you gotta stop saying things that
you know people wanna hear.
I'm in the trenches every day
I'm working, I'm grinding,
I don't know if it's
one of my background--
- Be specific to me on that.
- Man I feel like I don't know,
I feel like I always put
other people's not opinions,
but their feelings, I
guess above mine, right?
- I do too.
- Yeah and I feel like it
affects me in a negative way,
maybe not immediately,
but maybe down the road
or the relationship becomes--
- Road or the reverse, potentially.
- I guess so, yeah.
- Let's play it out.
Well give me a real like because I like
where you're going here lazar,
and I think we can help
you and a lot of people
so I'm interested in this.
Give me a black and
white, go real with me,
get a little naked, give
me a real life example
of the whole fucking,
give me the whole story.
- All right, man here you go.
I'll put it all up.
One of my clients is a luxury
dealership in Michigan here,
auto dealership, and it started off
we're just running
Facebook dynamic ads forum,
it started really working and
then he started, you know,
the GM, the owner started asking,
"Hey, what else can you do?
"Can you do a little more?
"Can you do a little more?"
And it was kind of just give, give, give,
and hey, it was my first big client
and starting the business--
- So you were doing more
things for the same scope?
Or were you asking for more money?
- Yes, I wasn't asking for more money.
Whenever I did, it was
kind of brushed off,
and it's gotten to the
point where I feel like
it's a more of an employee
rather than, you know,
the marketing arm for
them or their agency,
which I feel like I did
that to myself though.
- You did, but that's okay.
I don't think that's bad.
Let me ask you the other questions.
You've become very valuable to them?
- Oh yeah, I could sense that for sure.
- I can too without knowing shit.
So let's keep talking, do
you have other clients?
- Yeah, so well, we have
two other dealerships.
- What percentage of your
overall business do they control?
- My partners--
- Nope, this client.
This client's fee in
your overall business,
do some quick math.
- Oh man, that's the
thing it's huge, I'd say--
- How much?
- Probably 50% of our
revenue that's coming in.
- So you need to spend every waking hour
continuing to eat shit
and bring them value,
and every minute of your
life landing other clients,
every minute.
- Okay, now how do we ask
for referrals with them?
- You don't, put them in a box.
We're gonna put them on a
shelf a little over here.
No resentment, they've
been 50% of your revenue.
- Yeah.
- Like you've subconsciously
strategically over delivered,
because that's giving you stickiness.
- Absolutely.
- I love what you're doing.
The only part of this story
that I don't like so far is,
I want you to make them
8% or 12% of your revenue.
So I want you to slowly
not fear them going away
and kind of like take
a little of the energy,
and a lot of energy
away from your leisure,
your weekends, your other time,
with 100% strategy to
make them much smaller
of a percentage of your business,
and once they become 20% of your business,
I want you to go back to
them and say the gig is up,
and I need to ask for a
25 to 50% 100% increase,
and if not, we're going
to have to part ways.
What kind of contract you have with them?
- It was a six month contract,
and the after six months,
we just pushed it month
to month, so it's--
- Even better, even better.
Yeah, even better.
People see that as like you got fucked,
I see that as you've won.
- I was gonna ask you that.
- I want you to make it 20% you need me?
Oh, you love the advice, mom?
Thanks, Mom.
I got here all that cheerleading.
You need to make it 20% of your business,
and then you go in and
now you have the leverage,
and now they get scared
that you actually walk
and then you have the ability to walk.
- Awesome.
- And then at that moment
when they represent 18% of your business,
that's when you have to walk, got it?
- Like, should I just continue
doing what I'm doing then?
- I don't understand.
- It's just my personality, I guess--
- I don't understand the yes man,
I think they're demonizing a strategic,
I think you did everything right
except amortize out their leverage.
- Yeah, awesome.
- When you're in the service business,
you are in the yes business.
- Right, and that's why I
think I got to where I'm at.
- I say yes to all my clients
all the time, until I don't.
But you have to have the leverage to not.
- Absolutely.
One last quick question Gary.
How do I get unlocked out of Facebook man,
I was creating an ad last night midnight,
literally finished the
entire ad, put in my payment,
and then I got locked out of Facebook.
Dude, I don't know,
it's asking for my ID I uploaded it,
I've checked all these Reddit forums--
- Send me an email to Gary@VaynerMedia
I'll get my media team to help you.
- All yours man, I appreciate it brother.
- Talk to you soon, bye bye.
All right, let's keep going.
Keep it going, Kevin's back.
So Kev, no problem brother?
Hey, it's by treating him
like an adult and saying,
"Look, this may happen."
What's his name?
- Brady.
- Brady, listen, literally sit down,
you know, coffee, driving
however you guys roll.
"Brady listen something on my mind,
"I'm so proud of you and
you're fucking crushing it,
"but one thing that has
run through my mind Brady,
"and I want you to feel comfortable
"having this talk with me is,
"I'm potentially because you're young man,
"and a lot of things are gonna evolve,
"but potentially, you I find that
"you being so good at this
that you figured out a system
"and it's safe, I wanna make sure that
"you're happy not just
financially successful,
"and I hope you know, that
there's other ways to go about it
"than just going to a
safe job that pays well."
And then just seeing what Brady does,
the other thing in parallel,
is are there other things
that Brady's interested in?
- Yeah, I mean, despite the fact that
he does well in school,
he's a normal teenager.
I mean he plays Call of
Duty, he loves three sports,
he's a three sport athlete--
- Telling him that you
talked to GaryVee today,
the owner of the Minnesota
ROKKR Call of Duty team
do you like want to work
for that team one day
or do you wanna be at Esports,
like it's you creating
enormous conversation around,
if you make it not Brady,
I'm worried you're going to mail it in,
it comes so easy to you
and you're gonna live, that's more like
dad wants me to be ambitious.
If you put it into position of like,
"Hey, I want you to be happy,
"and you might find yourself at 41
"realizing you went safe the whole time
"and you may have resent or unhappiness
"I care about your happiness,
"not how successful you are."
Where kids get bucked and
where parents get fucked
is all the conversations
around how successful
AKA financially they are,
or status, not happy.
And I think you're
aiming down a happy path,
and I think if you keep
pounding the happy path
and play scenario play like "Hey, Brady,
"would you rather be a
lawyer making 630,000 a year,
"or a Call Of Duty marketing
executive and making 129?"
And just having those talks with him,
you need to navigate those combos.
Does that make sense?
- No, it makes perfect sense.
I think that's exactly what
we've started to do with him--
- And what have you seen?
So since you've a little bit,
is he just classic closed
off like whatever dad,
or is he kind of like leaning
in like what's happening?
- No his struggle is
that he likes to learn
and he is good at certain,
for the example the
other day he said to me,
he's like, "I'm thinking
about being an engineer,
"because I'm pretty good at math,
"and I should probably do some with that."
And I'm like, you know, maybe not--
- No, no, no, no.
- Let's find something that
you're passionate about,
and let's go for that.
- Play with me on this.
Say, "Brady, that's cool,
"you could also day trade stocks.
"Brady you could also run mass analytics
"for the government around defense."
What you wanna do in that sense
is not let him just
pick one option with it,
you need to almost educate yourself
on what math infrastructure
is on everything.
Or Brady you could be
the CFO, a back division,
you know, kind of going into his world
and why don't you be
the CFO of the Knicks?
Or, you know, what's his
favorite sports team?
- Sorry, sorry, again.
- What's his favorite sports team?
- That wasn't me,
I think he lost connection.
- Okay, let's go to next one
and we'll bring him back.
It'll be a three part series.
- Seriously.
- What's good?
- Hey, how you doing today?
- I'm really well, how are you, Scott?
- I'm all right.
My question is I turned 49 on Saturday.
- Happy birthday, bro.
- Thanks.
Where do you find your
passion or your why?
How do you do that?
I'm a factory worker,
and I've always thought all my life
I've tried different
aspects to find something
that gave me a reason to
get out of bed excited
or even want to get out of bed.
- I understand.
- How do you do that?
- Let's play, let's play.
Let's go into the
mindset of the following.
What do you tend to like to
do when you're not working?
- I love beer, sleep.
- Right because, you know,
I get it because you're depressed,
and you're like, not in that
great place, but that's okay.
- Well, I don't wanna
use this as an excuse.
- It's not an excuse.
- I do have clinical depression,
I've been for 15 years trying to find
different medications
and nothing's worked.
So basically my medication
for my depression
is watching videos like yours
and other motivational speakers.
- And does that work, that
entertains you that makes you
feel like you're living
vicariously through it,
you feel like that one
video might get you going,
you're looking for it.
How does that ride for you?
- Well, it just kinda gives me that,
okay, there's something better out there.
There's something--
- Well, there is, you know what's cool,
and it's not about you
missing a couple things,
you're gonna really like
this answer brother.
The first thing I need you
to do with all my heart
is realize how much you have an entire
nother life to live,
you need to know that,
like from the day you were born to today,
is the amount of time minimally,
in the ballpark of what you're gonna live.
Why I think that's
important is that Scott,
you and I grew up in a generation where,
remember when we were 16, 17,
like 49, 44 seemed like 1000.
But now that we're here, it's like,
wait a minute, it's not that thousand,
like there's still some real life to go.
So I think, first and foremost,
you have to realize how
much is in front of you,
and it actually doesn't matter,
the last 15 years, what
happened from 34 back,
it actually doesn't.
And what I mean by that is,
and why I'm so excited
we're here together brother,
I really am, I'm really,
genuinely passionately
optimistic about this moment,
is I think we're gonna
spend a few minutes here
and like chip away, and I understand
I talk to a lot of people theoretically,
in different scenarios
that may be similar,
maybe because everyone's
got different nuances.
Stick with me here.
So let's take away the
last couple of years,
let's take away the
motivational videos in general,
whether it's sports or music or food.
Give me a history lesson of Scotty,
like of things that you've kind of liked
wrestling, boxing like anything?
- Ah, you know, I've tried
to find that answer myself,
and I used to love to
camp and stuff like that,
when I was younger I was in the military,
I was pretty physically active.
I was always on the go,
I was not one that just
sit I couldn't sit,
I was always on the go.
In the last 10-15 years,
there's been nothing,
nothing, I have nothing that I can find
that just gives me that wants,
makes me wanna pick up and go.
- Talk to me about your inner
circle, positive or negative.
- I don't have much in my inner circle.
In fact, you know, just for example,
I had four happy birthday wishes.
One was my wife, one was my ex wife,
and then my stepson and
my son and in that order,
and you know, that was about it.
So you know, I used to
have more of a circle
I enjoy being around people,
I'm not a people person anymore.
- I understand because, when inside,
it's not a good thing,
it's hard to like make the outside work.
I totally have empathy for that.
Let me ask you another question.
Do you have any social media accounts?
- Just a Facebook account.
- And are you active on that?
- That's usually where
I get my video content.
- Do you comment?
- Occasionally, not a lot.
- Positive or more razzing?
- Well, I usually don't
comment unless someone
is like attacking someone for something
and then I jump in.
- I love that you defend people.
- Yeah, well, that's one
thing that I've always done.
I've always liked to
help people and stand up
for the little guy,
that's just my opinion.
- Me too, I like that.
I like the little Robin Hood
or like the bully buster.
- Well, sometimes it has to be done.
- I agree my man, I'm
just so genuinely happy
you're on here with me.
Here's a good one.
What in my content has
resonated with you if anything?
- I think the biggest
thing is, you just seem to,
you're not judgmental, I
mean you're straightforward,
I like that,
I like the fact that you
don't sugarcoat nothing,
You know, I myself, if you
got something to say to me,
I just want the truth,
don't be easy with me,
but don't be gentle.
But I think that you genuinely
are trying to help people,
and you're not necessarily trying to do it
to benefit yourself.
- Yeah, you know, hey, thank you.
You clearly have good
emotional intelligence.
You're right.
I wish everybody could feel my chemicals
right now in this moment,
because I'm so happy,
and I'm so conscious,
because I genuinely believe
that through words,
amazing things can happen.
Like, first of all,
I think it's nice to
have four family and ex,
ex wife you know, four
is better than zero.
I really mean that there's
just an ungodly amount,
I'm just very grateful too,
I appreciate you saying
I'm not judgmental,
that meant a lot to me,
it was a very good observation,
because you also followed
it up with being kindrous
and trying to shoot it because
I gotta honest with you,
man, like, life is so funny.
You know what this makes me
think a lot about, momentum.
I think a lot about momentum,
I think about it all the time.
You know, I love sports,
so like basketball super funny.
You know, I don't know
if you've ever watched it
or you follow it, but like, you know,
one team can go on a 13 hour
run, then there's a timeout,
you kind of gather yourself,
then that team can go on
a big run the other team,
and I think life is about momentum.
And I think a lot about fear too,
I was very fear based in a lot of things
as a kid like swimming,
riding bikes, kissing a girl,
they were scary to me,
and I was a late bloomer across the board
on all three of those things.
And then you do it and
it becomes normalized,
and like one of the things
I'm running through,
I'm talking to you in the corner
of my eye right over here,
there's a stream of like 10,000 people
that want to be your
friend, you can't see it,
it's in the live streams
I've got a stream that
shows me, Julian and Lizette
and MB and Oded, and
Scarlet, all on YouTube,
Facebook and Twitter all
like, I love this guy,
I wanna be Scott's friend,
I root for this guy,
and so I sit here and I'm like, man,
this is just a good old
fashioned game of like,
positive energy momentum.
Like you were 34 when this kicked in,
like you said for the
last 15 years, right?
- Right yeah.
- I gotta tell you, and I mean this Scott,
I am completely convinced
with my entire soul
that this is the moment that,
it can just start in the other direction.
- That's what I'm here for,
that's what I'm looking for.
I'm looking for that one thing that just
gives me that lets go.
- So Scott, are you
willing to share your email
so all these people who are
into hiking and outdoors man
and maybe hunting or fishing,
I'm playing here we're playing
and you can say no to anything you know,
okay he's giving me some context
that he used to like that,
where do you live?
- Indiana, Rensselaer, Indiana.
- To me back to, I was
scared to kiss a girl
but then you do it like, to me it's like,
what's going through my mind
to be transparent is like, would Scott,
go on a hunting trip, like
fishing trip with like,
a stranger that he then met on Facebook
got a lot more comfortable
through FaceTime,
because they email him right now
and he does it and that becomes a trigger.
to something he's liked,
and a new social graph,
how does that resonate in your head?
- Well, you know, fishing
I've always found very boring.
- I respect respect.
- And I don't look down
on people that hunt,
you know, it's it doesn't bother me,
I'm not a hunter myself,
I can't kill animals.
You know, in fact, I
generally like animals
more than I do people because they're--
- Not judgment, they're not judgmental.
- Exactly.
- I know where you're going.
- I don't have a problem
with meeting new people,
I don't wanna say that I am
afraid to meet new people,
I just don't know the words
to use about people right now.
Yeah, I guess I've just been let down
so many times by people and it's like,
I've isolated myself.
- Scott, you can't be let down
when you don't have expectations.
Let's play with that for a minute.
So I've been let down on paper,
an ungodly amount of times
because of the way I do business.
Similar to the kid earlier,
right, give, give give,
and a lot of times it
doesn't get reciprocated.
However, I take on full
accountability on my gift,
and I think this is an important insight.
I think that one thing to think about,
back to the next 49 years,
is, if you don't have expectations
to what you're giving,
truly, I mean this, and it's not so easy,
like, I'm not shooting it like,
but one of the things
that's really worked for me
is the ability to calibrate expectations,
I have too much empathy and sympathy
and compassion for other
human beings to expect them
to put me in front of themselves,
and in a weird way, that
realization allows me
to put other people in
front of my own self
and it's created a very charismatic, kind,
good energy that is sustainable for me
because I'm not
disappointed or judgmental.
And so, you know, for example,
what's really weird about
this meta moments got,
again, back to tens of thousands
of people watching this is,
if you allow me to have
you share your email
and if you actually go on FaceTime zooms,
and email and talk on Facebook Messenger
with these hundreds of
people that are set up
to talk to you, you should
see what's going on here,
people are like, in love with you,
don't forget the context
of you meeting them
is you being this transparent about,
that worry or things of that nature.
I am blown away by how many
people are golden hearted,
but I think it takes two to tango,
you also have to work on
yourself on expectations.
- I completely agree with that.
- Thank you for saying that.
- It's just, you need
positive people in your life,
I get that,
and I'm so scared that you meet someone
you think maybe they're positive and--
- Then they get you.
- Yeah.
- I get it.
- You know, the drag you
further down negatively,
and that is--
- I think if you go
into this next chapter,
maybe with this Vayner Nation community,
which is, people don't like me, you know,
I mean, there's a lot a lot of people
follow me at first because
they think I can help them
make more money,
but people that are watching right now
85% of them have a level
of humanity and kindness,
that I think is elevated
from the norm of contempt
on the internet.
And so I have so much
confidence in this community,
I feel like really excited,
I'll be very transparent with you Scott,
we've got we've been doing
this for a couple weeks now,
maybe a month or feels like who knows,
but there isn't even a close
second to my favorite call
than this and we've had
some bombers on here.
Because I'm completely
convinced as my chemicals
bounce in my body that
something incredible
is gonna happen here.
- I hope so.
And I didn't send my question,
so I could talk to you about finances,
I mean, granted, I would love
to be better financially,
but that's not what I need,
that's not important to me,
money has never been that
super important to me.
- Me neither, even though I
have the talent to produce it,
trust me good news,
I know that's not why you're here.
I, on the flip side, think there's no room
that you could have been
better than this one
for what you actually do need.
And I think this community
and I think why you've
been attracted to me,
is just all playing out.
You know, Scott, I think
about this all the time,
people talk about, you
know, COVID and Corona
being such a terrible event,
and that's absolutely true,
we've seen right death
tolls that make us all
shiver down our spines,
I'd be lying, if I didn't
tell you that I'm incapable of
not seeing the silver lining
and the optimism in this,
there is no chance in hell, that you and I
have these 20 minutes,
anyway ever without COVID,
it's just how I was navigating my life.
When I did Ask GaryVee or podcast,
I would be in such a tight short window
that I would have to cut
it off, cut it short,
the level of depth I'm
able to do on this show
is so different.
I genuinely believe in my soul right now
that your life will never
be the same after this,
I genuinely believe that.
And I think that that's
amazing as a collateral,
as an impact for what
happened in the macro.
And that makes me happy,
and that's how I think about the world.
- Right, and like I said, you know,
I'm not scared to meet new
people and move forward,
I'm just nervous.
- I think two things have to happen.
One, you have to do two
very important things.
Number one, we're gonna
share your email here
and you have to do two things for me,
one, you have to work on yourself
to not have expectations.
You have to be okay with Lisset, or Johnny
or Stevie or Jude or Matthew
or Jen stick to be okay,
with like warning about themselves too.
You know what I mean?
You have to be okay with that.
You have to be selfless
in their selfishness.
At the same token, you
also have to be very awake
to knowing that the people
that are about to reach out
in this community are
ready starting on third
and a half base around
kindness, compassion,
because they've also
gotten a lot of context
out of you in this call.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm ready, I mean.
- Let's do it, what's your email?
- Lone rider 71.
(laughs)
- Scott, you know what my number one
passion in life right now is?
A year from now for you to
send me an email and say
yo, I changed my email from lone rider,
to Scottsgang@gmail.com, that couldn't
that was literally out of Central Casting,
I love you with all my heart right now
for that fucking email.
- I don't know, it's missing right now.
- You know what's funny?
It is the perfect segue for this call,
it is going to be the last time that email
is going to really mean anything,
because I think that email is gonna start
the process of that
email changing over time.
So go ahead, let's put it up, lone rider.
- 71@gmail.com.
- Dustin, do your thing.
Let's make sure it's right.
Let's make sure.
- Yep, that's it.
- Scott, listen to me.
If you work on yourself around,
not expecting anything from
all these incredible people
that are emailing you right now
and everybody who's emailing,
listen, Scott's gonna have
to make some decisions here,
let's be empathetic,
you can't just be like,
hey, I wanna be your friend,
you need to write where you live,
what kind of interests you have, you know,
what's your family Facebook
so you can go on messenger,
what do you do?
Like, are you in paint balling?
Are you in gardening?
You need to pitch our friend here Scott,
because his friendship is valuable.
And so he's gonna pick some here.
Scott, I'm really excited about this.
- Well, I appreciate you taking the time,
I really do.
It means more to me than
you probably will ever know.
- You know what's funny, I
hear that at different times.
I really do know, like,
people need people,
you know, and back to your point of like,
well I haven't been able to do that
because you haven't
been in the best place,
I'm so grateful, and I'd
be frank with you, Scott,
also back to chemicals
and how this all works,
there's probably in that 80% gratitude,
there's 20% guilt, I'm
aware that I could have had
a DNA trait that activates
and this is not just like
hey, pick it up, these are diseases,
this is real life.
So I have so much good, I
want to put this energy.
Scott, I'm telling you right
now to your beautiful face
which I love your fucking
goatee by the way.
I'm telling you right now, brother,
you're about to shit your
pants, this is gonna be good.
Actually can you check
your Gmail right now,
just give me an update
on the email you got.
And by the way, everybody hope
you've been paying attention
make sure you wish him a happy birthday,
he's gonna go from four to 4000,
I just wanna get a sense of
how many emails you've got.
- Ah, they're still coming in.
- Look at the top, does it say at the top?
- Well, it says 12 so far,
but I haven't checked my
email in a couple days.
But, yeah, I got like five more
just in the last three seconds.
- You're gonna have a very, very, very,
very, very, very busy and exciting day.
- I think so yeah.
- And I think it's gonna change your life.
- Once again, I just thank you.
- You're welcome.
- All right.
- I wish you well, take care of yourself.
- All right thank you.
- Get back to all those
emails today, Scott.
- All right, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Let's keep it going.
(laughs)
- Third time's the charm Gary.
- It always is, brother.
- Yeah I literally drove
to my friend's office
because I think, like I
said, I got four kids,
and they're jamming the
wifi with right now.
- They're jamming it, school.
I think we're there, Kevin,
I think what you wanna
do is paint him pictures
that don't make his world narrow,
it's like, so maybe I'll be a developer,
and then you could say, "Well,
"maybe you'll be the CFO
of the of the Pacers."
You know what I mean?
I think you need to really push him
into dreaming opportunities,
where he's like, he's being
practical around a skill set,
but that skill set of math translates
in a million different ways.
And can layer to things
that he finds more fun,
which will then give him energy,
which will then drive him to
levels of success and happiness
that are far greater than
just taking a practical route.
- Right, I mean, here's a
different way to maybe ask it.
It's like, how do you manage a kid
and manage ain't the right word,
but you know, Shepard
would call it a kid who is,
frankly, perfectly designed,
at least by all accounts,
to play the game that is
education right now, right?
- By not over fearing it,
because you and I share
our ideology of like,
what the school system is,
by not over fearing it,
and by transposing that scale,
into things that make him happy.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, no, I think it makes
sense. I think it just--
- We have to be careful to
not over demonize school
the way that we grew up where
it was put on a pedestal,
how old are you my friend?
- 45.
- Right, so we're the same age.
I'm 44 turning 45 this year.
You know what I'm about to say,
there was no fucking other option,
tell these kids that are watching,
there was no entrepreneurship.
It was go to college,
and if you don't go to college,
there's a very big chance you
won't be happy and successful.
- Right, the whole
million dollar more number
that they threw around all the time.
- So now we're in a great spot,
but we need to be careful to
not over demonize it either,
and I think you need to
tap into his interest.
I love the three sports Call
of Duty stuff like love it.
And really also throw some things at him,
do some weird shit once in a while, like,
take them to a cooking class and be like,
"I know this blows and I know you hate me,
"but let's just talk sports
the whole time for two hours,
"and maybe God forbid you're
actually destined to be
"the greatest chef of all time."
- Yeah, it's a good point.
- Just mix it up, push.
And by the way, like,
push and then let go
maybe like it's real life.
Never get too caught always
be willing to adjust.
You book the cooking class 200 bucks each,
and then he just fucking
like just devastated,
and then you're like fuck
it fuck the 400 bucks
and you let him out of it.
That doesn't mean that
he's not seeing it through
that means you took a shot at an invasion
and didn't work that kind of stuff.
Do you see where I'm going?
- Yeah, no, I get it.
I mean, we're big on that, as parents,
I mean, back to the Call
of Duty thing it was,
or any video games when he was younger,
it was always, let him
play the video games
because he's doing everything
else fine academically,
and if we just kept pushing the academics,
pushing the academics,
he doesn't know anything
other than academics,
so let them go with it.
- Now it's the 3.0 version of that.
Now have more intellectual
theoretical conversations
with him to expand his mind.
- Yeah, no, I like that.
- Awesome, talk to yo soon brother,
take care of yourself, goodbye.
Good effort there, drove
to another planet, man.
I respect that.
Heinz what's good?
Mike Z what's good, Trucray what's good?
Be Adventures what's good,
Andrew Peasant what's good?
Kim Jacobs what's good?
Oh, we haven't done a wine
text thing, let's put it up.
We haven't done an All-In Challenge thing,
we're gonna end with all
challenge today again, Dustin?
Got that cute.
- Yeah, I still have it.
I wasn't sure if we're going to 11 or not.
- Think we might, think we might.
- Just checking.
- Just yet.
Winetext.com it is a thank you,
Winetext.com if you buy
wine on the internet,
or you buy wine at Total Tine or Bevmo,
or if you buy wine, and
you're not signed up for this,
you are breaking my dad's heart,
you're breaking my heart.
Oh, check this out.
I was making some commercials,
we're making some ads,
commercials, so now I'm sold,
ads for social media you know like this,
so I'm making some ads
for social check this out,
this is gonna hit your
Facebook and Instagram stream,
tell me what you think.
- [Gary] Hey dad, what do you think about
all those other wine sites
that people buy from?
- They suck.
They should sign up for winetext.com,
it will mean a lot to me.
- Sign up for winetext.com
because all the other services suck.
(laughs)
Man I love it.
Hey, please, please please please,
sign up for winetext.com it
would mean the world to me,
like literally $60 wine for 30 bucks
$40 wine for 14 bucks,
It is literally the best best best,
wine service in the world,
it's easy, it takes
two minutes to sign up,
it takes two seconds to order,
it's super fun, it's only 365 deals,
it's the best, it's the fucking best.
So please, please and if you don't drink
if you go to your
Facebook account right now
and say anybody who drinks wine
sign up for Wine text,
that would mean the world to me as well.
Let's watch it one more time
because everybody loved it.
It's really good.
- Hold your mic closer to the phone.
- [Gary] What do you think
about all those other
wine sites that people buy from?
- They suck, they should sign up for
winetext.com, it will mean a lot to me.
- Sign up for winetext.com,
watch this, look what my dad's doing.
(laughs)
Make my dad happy,
like literally people
signing up for Wine text,
by the way, don't sign up for
it just to make my dad happy
because if you don't buy anything,
it costs money to send a text,
so we don't need that.
But if you drink wine, it
would mean the world to me.
All right, let's keep it going.
And let me know you've signed up.
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh my god.
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm well.
- That's awesome, I'm doing tea.
- I'm doing tea, let's
do it Katie, cheers.
- I want you to do cheers right there,
I love it, I love it, man.
So first off, I just wanted to say
thank you for having me on the show,
but for more importantly,
you're changing lives man.
- I'm trying.
- No you are, you just
change people's lives
in a way that I think
is absolutely fantastic.
And if I'm being real with you,
what I feel like my purpose on this earth
is to connect deeply with people
and inspire them to live
a more meaningful life,
and so much of that has been influenced by
your teaching, has been
influenced by others,
and is really just I look
up to you as someone,
I wanna do what you're doing.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, of course.
- Do you do you have the
patience to pull it off?
Because the thing that--
- Absolutely.
- The thing that you'll
need to do is do things
that build up the credibility
for the messaging to land.
- Absolutely, I absolutely
believe in that,
and it's not something,
it's not a tomorrow thing,
it's something that I'm
doing for the rest of my life
if this is what I'm going to be doing,
and maybe I make it when I'm 80 years old,
and I make a difference in someone's life,
that's what I'm here for,
and that's what I'm gonna be going for it.
- I'm proud of you.
- So my question, thank you.
My question today is I've been struggling
to kind of find a path that
aligns with that vision.
So I'm a high school senior,
I'm about to graduate,
and I'm trying to really figure--
- Real quick, how did
everybody feel about like,
what's the vibe, how many kids you have
in your graduating class?
- We have about 600, maybe a little more.
Yeah, yeah.
- Where do you live?
- Hillsborough New Jersey.
- You live in Hillsborough New Jersey?
- Yeah, why?
- You know that I went to
North Hunterdon high school?
- No way, bro that's sick, that's so cool.
- Wait a minute, Hillsborough
High has 600 fucking kids
graduating from high school?
- Yeah, yeah, we are packed.
We do not have room for
it but we have them.
- Do they still have like a
football trophy for Ricky Prole,
the wide receiver who
went to Hillsborough?
- I don't know, I wish
I could tell you but--
- Fair enough, Katie you do you know that
we're like 20 minutes
apart right this minute?
I'm in Hunterdon New Jersey right now.
- Dude that's literally insane.
- Okay so what's the vibe?
Was everybody like devastated
about prom and graduation?
- Absolutely, absolutely,
people are just devastated
about it and it's--
- Go ahead, I'm sorry.
- No, it's totally good.
It's just totally changed
not only our senior year,
but our outlook for what
we're doing next year,
which is totally.
So like, for me, this kinda
gets into my question,
so, I've been kind of, my focus has been
one optimizing for a great
experience after high school
and really just connecting with people
who are going to push me towards the path
that I'm supposed to take,
and for me those two options
I've kind of narrowed down
to either taking a gap year
or going straight to the
college that I'm accepted to.
- And which one's that?
- UVM, University of Vermont.
So I'm kind of in between
these two circumstances
but coronavirus has really added
this extra level of frustration
because my gap year and
my freshman experience
could look totally freaking' different.
- That's good.
- So yeah.
- No frustration.
If you're gonna do what you wanna do
and your energy is so awesome,
and everyone's loving you in the comments,
you need to understand
that plans are shit,
it's good to have a plan,
but the ability to adjust
to reality is the ultimate.
- Let me tell you this,
so what I've been doing,
I actually had a conversation
with one of my mentors
who works at TED so it's my
dream to work at TED talks
you know, all of that one of
my big dreams to work there.
So I'm totally passionate
about their vision
and really aligned with their mission.
- I don't know if she's still
the CEO, but I might be able,
you need to email me at Gary@vaynermedia,
I still know the president,
I don't know if she still holds the job,
but she clearly knows
a lot of people there
and I might be able to help you.
So don't forget.
- That'd be fantastic, I
will, I will not forget.
But I was talking to one of my mentors
who actually works at TED
and we're basically everything in my life
I try and look through the
lens of everything for me,
not against me.
So what I try and do is
to if something happens,
corona, okay, how can we make this worthy?
- Katie, then I need
you to stay true to that
and not say frustrated about the gap year
fucking' Vermont then.
- Yeah, no, you're absolutely right.
- I know, let's sit here.
Like, I'm serious with you because
I see the potential in you.
- Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Your energy is just sweet
and fucking awesome.
- Thank you.
- But then you need to
listen to me right now,
like fuck that frustration,
don't get caught up in a bubble
of what you're supposed to
feel, you're not frustrated.
- I'm not saying--
- I can feel it.
This is important part of the evolution,
this is the training, we're
on some Jedi shit now.
I actually don't believe
that you're frustrated.
- No I'm not, I'm excited about it.
- But you're parroting words from others,
you're taking the energy
from the ones that are.
- Yeah, that's true, that's true.
- So that's why we need
to focus on this moment
because this is a good way for you--
- Let's do it, let's do it.
- No more parroting other energy,
speak your fucking truth.
You can be in a gap year your
whole fucking' life Katie.
- Yeah, no, I was looking at that.
- You know what I mean, like gap year
meaning doing what the fuck you want.
- Absolutely.
And I'm still trying to figure out
what exactly that looks like, right now,
in the personal development--
- Don't, I'll let you finish in a minute,
but don't put it into
process you already know
exactly what it looks like,
you just told me what you're gonna do,
I always knew what I was gonna do it too.
You know what my process looked like?
I worked in my dad's
liquor store for 15 years.
- Absolutely, and I--
- Do think it was the
clear path to fucking
like to impacting people's lives?
Carrying fucking cases of Korbel Brut
into people's fucking backseats?
No, if you're into patience,
then you're not overvaluing
process upfront.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Now to fall and love with that process
is something that I have
been definitely holding core
to who I'm trying to become and--
- Katie do you know what
I'm basically telling you?
- What?
- It's not gonna matter.
What I mean by that is,
it doesn't matter if you go to Vermont,
or if you go to a gap year,
if you're an internet head,
or if you work at a coffee shop in Aspen,
or if you go in a car with your friends
and drive cross country,
or if you go to Ireland for three years.
If it's your destiny, if
it's what you're about,
you will absolutely process through,
and so whether you have
an Instagram account
that has 43 followers on it or not,
whether you go viral and Tik Tok or not,
whether you execute on
the thing that happens
19 years from now, that's
invented by somebody,
we haven't even started,
and you need to stay on the macro mission
and not overvalue the micro mission.
Actually, it's just not gonna matter.
- Yeah, no, and I totally agree with that.
I think that was something I was,
as I was preparing for this show,
I kind of, I got to
that in a way of saying,
you know what, I have this purpose,
and really, I think people
look for the perfect place
to live out their mission,
and really you can do your purpose,
you can do your mission
literally wherever you're going,
and that's really what I wanna do.
- We're doing it right now.
- Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
I'm super excited about it, thank you.
- You're welcome.
How do you, paint me a picture,
and it will change 39
times so no pressure,
paint me a picture of is exactly
what you're doing when you're 44 go.
- Exactly what I'm doing when I'm 44?
- Yeah, hot take.
- I want to be traveling
and meeting people
helping people going to,
hopefully I will amass a
large amount of knowledge
and skills that can help people
and add value to their lives--
- Do you see that, and how--
- Hello.
- Wow.
Oh, Gary, you dropped off for a second.
- I did?
Am I back?
- Yeah, you're back.
- Okay, cool.
- Okay, bye.
- Hey.
- Hey, sorry.
So you have this incredible
framework of selflessness.
- Thank you, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Which I also have, what is selfish to you?
Do you want statues?
Do you wanna be famous?
Do you want money?
No, all of these are okay,
do not demonize them.
What do you think you want and or need?
- So I know--
- Don't give me some
altruistic, selfless thing.
- I got it man, I got it.
- "Cause I wanna help you, go ahead.
- All right so I know
that I need enough money
to live the life of my
dreams so what that means is,
having experiences that I
think are freaking' amazing
and that energize me that
I think are vibrant that--
- Like is that going to like
some weird mountain in Peru
and like drinking the the
tea of some rare fruit,
out of the asshole of
like some weird animal,
like you're into that fuff shit?
- It's doing all of it,
it's experiencing life to the absolute,
like highest degree.
- But how do you define that?
Is it in the form of fuff?
Like I'm a fuffy guy,
but I don't need to go to some mountain
and hang with some gurus in silence
and drink like bee urine, but
some people love that shit
like are you about the bee urine or not?
Like you love that shit like
India in a cave for a month
like and mud on your, are
you into that fuff shit?
- I'm a little bit, in the middle.
I think I love some of that,
I think pushing my boundaries
of what's comfortable
I think is freaking' awesome,
so doing some of that is awesome.
But I also want to be able
to be financially free
and not have to really stress on--
- So do you want people people
to pay you as their coach?
- I'm not sure.
- Great, that's a great answer.
- If that's the way that I make my money,
and that's what gives me the
financial freedom I need,
then absolutely I think that's great.
- Does it run through your
mind of starting a sentence
like life is good and building like
a $5 million a year hoodie company?
Does that run through your mind ever?
Are you that kind of person?
- That definitely does, I've
definitely thought about it,
because I'm definitely into,
like I even getting back
to this idea of optimizing
the experience of what can
we do with coronavirus?
I had this idea to basically
how can we recreate
the freshman experience in a virtual space
where you're only kind
of creative constraint
is the fact that everything
has to be online?
So again, it's creating
those random collisions
it's creating those deep connections,
those deep conversations with new people
so I definitely had thoughts like that
of creating something,
a program a business,
something like that.
- I love it.
Katie, I'm gonna tell you something
I hope you re watch over and over,
you're 100% gonna win life.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I'm positive, I'm positive.
- Yeah, thank you.
- I'm positive.
Keep it simple, keep an eye open.
I like your framework, I like your energy.
- Yeah, well--
- How many people follow you on Instagram?
- Not a lot, I have maybe 83 followers.
- Not for long.
- Thank you, thank you.
And I do have a question.
And you're feel free to say no.
- No problem.
- But I'm here and I wanna--
- You follow five people that fires me up,
you know that's my number?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- You literally follow five people.
You follow five people.
- Yeah.
- NASA, Manifested Mines, TED Education,
National Geographic and me.
- Yep.
- It's cool.
- Thank you, man.
So I do have a question.
- Watch this Katie.
- Yeah?
- You've already doubled.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Go ahead, I'm listening.
- So I'm definitely going to
continue doing this mission,
but I gotta say, I have
this moment to be bold,
so I'm gonna be it.
You talk about finding
a leader who's doing
what you wanna be doing
and working them for free.
- Yeah.
- You also said, to find someone and say,
"What can I do for you, I'm hungry."
So GaryVee, what can I
do for you? I'm hungry.
- Can you create?
Because we're gonna be hiring--
- Absolutely.
- Like, are you writer?
You know, my content well?
- I'm a writer yeah, I do.
- Alright, send me an email,
I would tell you right now that you have
a significant chance of being
able to get a job with me.
- Absolutely, thank
you so much, thank you.
- But you know what Katie,
you might not want that job
because right now,
you're already up to 278
I feel like you're gonna be in 1000
before this video is over.
Katie send me an email, I'm
gonna introduce you to TED
and I'm gonna introduce you to Andy Kay,
who runs my team and we're
gonna vet your creative talents,
'cause right now in TeamGary,
we're only hiring makers,
people that help make
content for LinkedIn,
for Facebook either you have
to design make videos or write,
so I'm into it.
- Absolutely.
- In the title it's Gary@VaynerMedia
put Katie from Tea time
and New Jersey plus Dustin
will get connected with you,
actually work with Dustin,
Dustin you can take care of that, right?
- Okay, cool.
- I got you,
- Katie, Katie, look, 353 Katie.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, keep
going, talk to you soon.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
- Okay bye bye.
It's a good episode.
Kam.
- Hi, Gary, oh, man, this is insane.
- Where are you from?
Where are you from, Kam?
- Thank you for everything for start,
I'm always grateful for everything you do
in bringing that value, you
saved my life numerous times.
And I couldn't be more
than grateful for that.
Seriously, thank you.
- You're welcome, where are you from?
- I am originally from
Peru born and raised--
- Oh my god, I just said fucking Peru.
- Yeah, I know.
- How the fuck?
See Kam this is why, out
of all the fucking things
when I'm painting the
weird picture to Katie,
I said Peru out of any
fucking place on earth
and then you're fucking not.
- It's all connected.
- Yeah, fuck it this is
the fucking fufu shit
that fucks with me Kam.
- Straight up man.
- This fucks with me Kam,
this fucking fucks with me.
- It's all connected because, you know,
man, it's so deep, man, it's so deep.
So just like with you, you
know, you're an immigrant.
I was an immigrant for years,
matter of fact, when I first came here,
I had to go back because my dad, you know,
he was doing crazy things.
So when I came back, my mom remarried
and I was still working on my paperwork
getting my green car
finally was able to do that,
So fast forwarding school was not for me,
but I was still an A and B student,
but I ended up dropping out because of..
- We lost Kam.
- I'm still here, I'm still here.
- You ended up dropping out because of--
- I'm still here.
- I'm with you.
- Okay, can you hear me?
- Yep, yep, I can hear you.
- Okay, awesome, awesome.
I can't really hear you though.
- No, we lost that part.
- Kam try just reloading
the page and coming back.
- Oh, I can hear you, I can hear you.
- Okay, good.
Wait, wait, can you can
you hear Dustin but not me?
I don't think she can hear me.
- Yeah, Kam.
Can you actually just reload
the page and then come back in?
- Sure, yeah, I can hear, okay.
- You could hear me but you
probably can't hear Gary.
- Kam, can you hear me?
- Okay, okay, I'll reload the page.
- I guess I'll stay here for a second.
- Well, thank you Dustin, for
keeping me entertained while--
- I'd really like to see somebody so--
- That's in the fufu stuff.
Like that was fucking crazy.
Did you know Kam was from Peru?
- No, she actually
mentioned it in the comments
and I was like, I'm pretty
sure we're in a simulation.
(laughs)
- Well, you are dude,
you're fucking 35 and you look 3.5,
and I just can't get over that shit.
Kam, can you hear me?
- All right, we're back,
we're back, we're back.
Yeah I can hear you Gary.
- So go ahead.
- Thank you.
Anyway dropping out, I went
to Colorado lived everywhere,
long story short, I got
into the media business,
and I was doing promoting
for music festivals,
traveling and doing things like that.
But my mom it's just my mom here living,
now she divorced there's
a lot of things going on
and just like you helped your dad
build this incredible business,
I feel the same way you know,
all my family's in Peru, all of them.
And me I feel like there's
all this responsibility
on my shoulders to create
the wealth necessary
and I'm not I mean, I love
the financial industry
because that's that, you know,
and I got into that, at first I was like,
you know what, it's just gonna work out,
I'm all about marketing,
but I fell in love with it.
And, you know now just
wanting to create that wealth
for my family building a legacy,
and wanting to obviously go back to Peru,
helping out children there,
helping out children here
in our community as well,
my question is--
- Go ahead, I wanna hear it.
- Yeah, my question is,
being pretty much the person
who is leading the way
of not just, you know,
with my legacy that I
wanna create for my family,
I know that it took a long time for you
to build that business for your dad,
and right now, obviously,
you know, my family's broke,
my family's broke and
I'm over here thinking,
all right, I'm in this new business--
- Kam, you're gonna lose
if you wanna go fast.
- That's my question.
- I know, I almost interrupted you,
I already have the answer,
the answer is slow.
And that goes counter cultural,
because every day that
goes by is another day
that you envision them struggling.
- Exactly.
- But Kam, I'm gonna
throw a real bomb at you
that you as an immigrant know,
and a lot of other people here
who've come from immigrant
or humble beginnings.
They're not struggling
as much as you think.
Because when your context is your life,
and your life is your context,
you now know what you want
them to have here in America,
but they haven't tasted that yet.
So you're creating an
ideology of pressure,
like I've got to get my grandma,
my mom, my aunt over here
so they can have it good in America,
but they're not struggling as much as
you create in your mind
because that's their reality.
I wasn't struggling when I
had way less I was happy.
And if you try to go fast,
you're gonna cut corners
and actually lose.
- That's how I feel about the situation,
I'm new to the--
- You have to reframe the situation.
If your perspective is that
you have to go fast for them
instead of you have to go
slow to ever pull it off,
and that these next three years,
they'll still be super fine,
because that's where they're from,
that's what they know.
Do you understand this is
where immigrants in America
always get caught, but Gary
I gotta get my family here,
I'm like, how bad is it?
Are they like in jail?
Are they in a dangerous zone?
Are they in a war zone or drugs zone?
And nine out of 10 times they're not,
they're like yeah, "But
their running water."
and like, But they've always known
"the running water wasn't great."
"Yeah, but they want to have new clothes."
I'm like, "But they've lived
in the same clothes forever."
Like we can't impose a
capitalistic wealthiest country
in the world on them,
because they're content.
Of course they'd love to be here more
because they just miss you,
not because they wanna eat
at fucking Shake Shack.
- Yeah, no, exactly.
- I know.
- I miss them, I haven't
seen them in 13 years.
- You need to go back and see them.
You need to worry about going slow
and flipping some shit on eBay
to save for a plane ticket
not to fucking win the lottery,
you're going for the Hail Mary.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Don't.
You could have seen them twice,
if you have the perspective
I'm trying to have you have.
This isn't about you
fucking bringing them over
and having a mansion
that everybody lives in,
that's your ego talking.
- No, you're absolutely right.
You know and, of course,
I'm obviously going to work hard and--
- I believe it.
- You know, obviously give it my all,
develop every single day,
so that I can become that
person that I ought to become.
And just like you said,
listen to everything
that you mentioned the humility,
the patience, the strategy,
and, you know, I definitely
got to be patient,
you know, because right
now I'm in the business,
and everybody's going super fast.
You know, they're messaging,
they're DMing people
two 300 messages, and
I'm over here thinking,
I don't wanna be a spam
but at the same time,
I don't know like, how to go about it,
you know how to go about the burning part.
- By making content.
I made content for so
long before anybody came.
But you also can do side
stuff, you can save money,
you can find money, you
know, that's why I love camp,
why I love the flipping stuff.
If you've got that in you,
like that's the quickest
way to make $3,000,
is goodwill and garage sales.
And immigrants have the
humility to go and drive
and pick up shit.
- Exactly, exactly, and right now,
I actually did that, matter of fact,
I did flip a lot of
things on offer at Lego--
- How'd it go.
- It went pretty well,
I did sell some stuff
and I liked that concept of going out
and you know picking out random things
and then flipping it for more.
- I'm telling you right now
every year you can go to Peru,
if you garage sale every
weekend for a couple hours
and ship out some stuff on the week.
I'm telling you right now you can.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I'm gonna do that no seriously
because I have to go back
to Peru and see my family,
it has to happen this year.
- You have to, you wanna go back
when you've already did something,
like you're trying to be a hero,
just be a family member.
- I know and that's the thing, you know,
like every now and then
my mom is struggling
so she asks us you know for money
and I'm obviously gonna have it
but my story, my backside was story,
I went homeless for almost two years
and, you know, I'm still
decorating my apartment,
I'm still trying to,
obviously build myself up
and build my blueprint.
And so I got into the business
of insurance and finances,
and I love it.
You know, I'm learning more about money
and things like that,
now, I'm not like, oh, you know,
I have to, like money is
life happiness it's not,
it's about the process, what
you're doing for families too.
But that leads to the question as well,
like, everybody's going super fast,
you know, everybody's
building up a big team,
and I'm over here doing my
thing, creating content,
branding myself, obviously providing
as much value as possible,
but I don't know if that's a good strategy
to be DMing two to 300 people a day.
- Here's the good news.
Why don't you DM 100 people
a day, offer some value,
do it a little less spammy
and see what it feels like,
when you don't know the
answer you have to do.
What most people do in life
is when they don't know the answer,
they debate it in their
own head and do nothing.
They look at other people who've done it
and do whatever they said
without contextualizing
how it impacts them.
I don't want anybody to do anything I say
other than you live their life,
fully themselves the way
I do and at least hear out
the tactics that I put
out that might bring value
and see if it brings value,
not debate if it does or
blindly believe that it does.
So the answer to your question that is
try it for a week and
see what it feels like,
and if you feel spammy and
gooky and ugly, then stop.
You know me and my friends don't like,
I like to eat exotic food, I
grew up in the wine business,
so French cuisine, like
flog rod, sweet breads,
and all sorts of weird oysters,
I'm a very exotic eater.
When I'm out a lot of my
friends or business associates
are like, "Oh, I don't like oysters."
And do you know that
more than half of them
have never had one.
- Really?
- And that's how I think about this,
you don't know what it feels
like to DM 200 people a day,
so you have to taste it, try it.
- And give value to them, right?
All the values see--
- It's not the tactic, it's
how you feel the tactic.
- Exactly, because I'm
over here, you know,
learning about money too, and I'm like,
okay, obviously financial
literacy is very important,
and there's other things
that come with it,
like the leadership, building up somebody
and things like that and
so I'm doing that myself,
and I see a lot of people
my age who struggle,
people who went through
the same course of life,
and I'm like, okay,
like, this is what I did,
you know, this is how
that of the situation
how I went from homeless
to having a lease at home,
and little things like that.
So when I'm creating the
content to help people,
with the financial literacy,
I know it's boring,
I know it may be boring--
- But you're not boring.
- Yeah.
- You got it Kam I trust you.
- I know, man.
I'm gonna get it done.
- Kam get to Peru.
- For sure no, I got to get there, I do.
- Kam, number one,
because you'll regret it
when people aren't there anymore,
when you go in six years,
you need to go immediately.
- Yeah this year, definitely.
- Look, you have to be practical,
I don't know what your money situation is,
you're gonna have to figure it out
but I'm telling you right out flip life
I'm telling you right
now flip life is real.
- Yeah, for sure, for sure.
Just about being patient
I'll continue listening
to your content man,
I love everything you do,
and you know being able to
donate in All-In Challenge
that's something that
I that I look forward
to do someday you know,
being able to help all these children
and people in hungry
like I grew up in that,
I was like in Peru poor
third world country you know,
like I know that.
- I get it.
- And I'm very passionate about this,
but overall, I just am very
grateful for this moment,
thank you for giving me some value,
absolutely Gary.
- You got it, talk to you soon, bye bye.
On that if you don't know
what the All-In Challenge is
right now, allinchallenge.com
in a little bit
I'm gonna show the
video my offer is crazy.
The ultimate GaryVee
experience it's a raffle
$10 tickets to enter,
I fly you to three of my keynotes,
you sit front row, sit in
the green room with me,
I spend a week with you at VaynerMedia
and work on your content with my TeamGary
will and I'll jump into a bunch of stuff,
you go garage sale with me,
go to a Jets game with me
and tailgate sit with me,
I won't talk to you during the game
because that's how I roll,
$25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library,
get to be on my podcast,
it's gonna be pretty legit.
So check out allinchallenge.com
Scorsese and Leo are letting
you be in their movie,
Justin Bieber will come to
your home and serenade you,
this is some real shit.
So allinchallenge.com please check it out.
We've raised $13 million in a week,
launched a week ago actually,
not even six days ago,
$13.4 million have been raised
and we're very proud of it,
very proud, I'm sure you've seen all over,
celebrities athletes
just been unbelievably,
unbelievably incredible.
Let's sneak another one.
- Hey Gary, what's up, man?
- What's up Uncle Pudge.
- How you doing, man?
how's quarantine life?
- It's going well.
I'm a big lemonade out
of lemons kind of guy,
and so that's where we're at.
- 100% yeah, this whole
thing has really helped me
have some good quality time with my family
that we haven't ever gotten before,
so I'm super pumped about it.
- By the way.
- So I wanna start by just
there's not a long enough livestream
that we could do to tell
you how grateful I am
for everything that you've put out,
I've been following you
since August 23 2018,
and I have literally consumed everything
you've ever put out unless
it requires me to do reading
because Like you, I don't read things.
I've read all of your books
that are on audio book,
and I wanna give you a
little bit of context
on who I am before I go into my questions.
So I'm a 31-year-old stay-at-home stepdad,
and on the side, I've got this dream
to create a communications machine,
similar to what you're
doing with Sasha group,
and VaynerMedia.
So that's my dream to be
able to help small businesses
and organizations and
nonprofits and different things
like that help them to
communicate with their audience
in their communities
and build a community.
So which leads me into
both of my questions.
The first of which is
a lot more practical,
and then the second is
something that I think
I've struggled with the word
that I need to use today
with this question.
I need your wisdom on, okay?
- I can do it.
- So my first question is,
I am a part of the creative
story team for my church.
And I see a lot of churches
struggle with communication,
with digital content, with
building communities online,
definitely in smaller town--
- All day, yeah very archaic models.
- Right, and I think a lot
of that has to do with fear
and a lack of understanding for sure.
- Always and leadership just
being stuck in old ways.
- Right 100% I totally agree.
The model model that I
follow is Brady Shearer
with Pro Church Tools,
who actually uses a lot of your logic
when he talks to to churches
and helps them to communicate
in what he calls the 167.
So there's 168 hours in a week,
we spend one of that in church
and churches struggle
with the communication
in those 167 hours in between.
- Makes sense, makes sense.
- So that's what my goal is,
in being on that creative story team
is helping churches
understand the concept of
functioning as a business
and organization,
without letting go of the
anchor that they have,
which is their message.
- I totally understand.
- So what can I do there to help--
- By making content by
yourself around video games
or other like looking at your setup,
appreciate the mug life
and the empathy stuff--
- Yeah you know, every
time I go garage selling,
that's the shirt I wear.
- So when I see the N64
games in the background,
I think if you make content for you,
and then show it success to the church,
and you're like, this is what works
because if you try to do
it through the church,
you're gonna bang your
head against the wall,
you're gonna get nothing
accomplished, you're in the system.
This is how I think about education,
the education system is rigid,
education is the most
important thing in the world.
How you do education
can be done different,
we've been doing some real
fucking' education here
for two hours this morning.
- 100%.
- So I think you need
to prove it through you,
and then put it on a silver platter
for everybody at the
church to look at and say
"What I really wanna do
is do it for the 167."
- See this is why I never
text questions to you,
because I always know what
your answer is gonna be,
because you've already
answered the question
in every bit of content
you've ever created.
- The strategy--
- Go ahead.
- is to put out all my
best advice for free
and then use the serendipity
of non scalable moments
like this, to drive it home,
to use the energy exchange right now,
to be like, you know, you know the answer,
sometimes it's literally
this to be like...
- And yeah you're 100% right.
So that's why I always struggle with
sending in questions to you.
But I totally agree with that.
So and--
- So why aren't you doing it?
- That's leading me into
the second part, I am.
- I love it.
- But I struggle.
So and I'll preface my question with this.
So at the beginning of this year,
I started doing what I
call the 366 challenge,
where I decided to
create a piece of content
every single day and it
started with video content,
I was making videos every single day,
I got a camera for Christmas,
I got a mic set up that
I'm doing my podcast with,
so, you know, it's
relatively high quality.
But--
- It's not the tool, brother.
- You're right, you're 100% right.
- Yes Dustin.
- The feed's coming in really weird
so just give me one second.
- No worries.
- I wonder if it's, I don't know who.
- So it's correct.
- That's right.
- Aren't making.
- It's just us for some reason.
- Are we good?
Talk to us Dustin.
- Test test test.
- 749, I can hear you.
- I can hear you.
- Everyone's.
- You guys are coming in
like really robotic to me.
- Got it, okay, no worries.
How about for everybody else?
What's going on in the comments?
Looks good on his end.
- It's good at my end.
- Looks good here, looks good here,
sounds fine yeah, I think it's you Dust.
In fact, you know what, that porn plugin
that you have on your computer,
sometimes drains a lot of
energy, so I would take that out,
I've seen what you do on your work stuff.
So it's that, you may want
to take that plugin out.
- Okay.
- Got it, all right, go ahead.
- So I started this
one this 366 challenge,
at the beginning of the year,
where I decided to create
a piece of content every single day,
focusing on video in the beginning,
to first of all work on myself,
and it became this journey into myself,
where it was this
transparent journal almost,
that I was posting on social media,
writing down my deepest
innermost fears and thoughts,
and it became a journey into myself,
but at the same time, what I want to do
was help build a portfolio
and credibility and context
around what I wanna do with my business.
- So what's the problem?
- I don't have confidence in myself.
- Well then let's get
confidence in yourself.
- The second part of
this is my real struggle,
after about 20 or 30 days of it,
I started to think too much--
- Of course because you
weren't getting enough views,
because you got a negative
comment, because--
- No, I never got any negative comments.
Every piece of feedback that I ever got
was totally positive, people in my church
were coming up to me,
people in public were coming up to me--
- Not enough views for your self esteem?
- I really try to do my
best to take your advice
and not even look at that.
I try not to even look at the likes--
- Is it your overall framework?
Like did you grow up in environments--
- It's me, I grew up sexually abused,
I grew up physically and mentally
and verbally abused in my home,
I moved to Mississippi when I was 11,
and brand new school in
sixth grade got beat up
every single day from
sixth grade to ninth grade,
and I got big enough to where people
stopped messing with me.
- Thank God.
- Which I know you can
relate with because--
- Except I didn't get get big enough.
I didn't get big enough,
I got charismatic enough
and smart enough and clever enough.
- Yeah, you get big enough here,
but here is where--
- I also for transparency
really didn't have that issue.
Because I had a personality
trait that was so confident,
so likable, that it
didn't make me vulnerable
to your point, when you're insecure.
It's 100%.
- Your home life.
- Brother all I'm trying
to do for the world
is what my mom did for me.
- Absolutely, and that's what
I'm trying to do for my kids
because I grew up in a toxic environment,
and yeah, I'm trying to do that for my son
who has his own YouTube channel--
- You're playing it right.
If you've consumed that much of my content
and you need to continue to pump complete
and utter positivity into your soul,
to out balance the negativity
and it's not one for one,
that kind of level of abuse as a child,
that's like 1000 to every
one minute I can put into you
or anything else that's positive
and practical self esteem
building and believing.
But brother, you're on your
way like when I sit here,
and I've been through
a lot of these rodeos,
you're very on your way.
- I need that Gary.
- Good I just gave it to you.
- I need that's not connected to me,
that doesn't love me.
- I unfortunately love you,
so you're gonna have to
sit a little bit of
consult, but I definitely,
I'm not connected yet
to you, but now we are,
and the reality is, I
just am good at this,
and I just think you're on your way.
And if you have to re watch this clip,
clip this 14 seconds, and
play it on repeat every day
and make.
- I wonder if a lot of my mental hurdle
is the fact that I don't
have enough portfolio
or credibility because--
- Nope, that's not it.
- It's not a thing that
I've ever done before.
- It's your own insecurity manifesting.
It's just a framework, it's
just where you came from,
the news you fought,
because you had it in you
to get out of it, and you're on your way,
you're on your real way,
and now you're just early in the process.
- And that's not the only one thing
that I try to keep up in my mind,
is to understand that every single day
I repeat to myself 10
years, 10 years, 10 years.
I've been doing this for over a year now.
- And by the way, and when you get there,
you're gonna say 10 years again.
At 34 I was like, 10 years, 10 years,
now I'm 44 and guess what I'm saying?
I'm gonna fucking kill at 54,
54 is gonna be fucking crazy.
Bro, you're on your
way, you're on your way.
- I'm excited to be connecting with you,
and I know you just had
a conversation with Katie
and look, I hate being
the the follow up person
to do something like this,
but you know you talk about a lot
if there's something that you wanna do
to get as close as you can to the sun,
of that, to feed off of that energy.
- I'll save you time if
you want to apply to Andy
for my team, I'm never against
it, it's a real filter.
You know, I'm always
comfortable saying no,
it's a super coveted
job so it's competitive,
but it doesn't scare me to
give you that opportunity,
you're just gonna have to, you know,
you're gonna have to
get through the filter
of some pretty hardcore
subjective opinions
based on the merit of
the work that we can see.
To make that decision,
you also have to move to
the New York City area
in an entry level capacity financially,
just a reality of the job
at the starting point,
they are just like anything else.
And so if those things match
up, I'm not against it.
- 100% what do you want me to do?
- Dustin will take care of you.
- Gotcha.
- That's it brother, I'm 30 minutes late
for my meeting, I love you
back, Dustin get out here.
And thank you so much for
being on the ones and twos,
thank you everybody who's watching today,
I thought today was remarkably strong.
I'm really enjoying it, I
hope TeamGaryVee was watching,
I think there's a lot of Instagram clips,
and most of all, it would
mean the world to me
if you went and bid on
the GaryVee experience,
$10 raffle ticket you can
buy 20 of them for 100 bucks,
so five bucks a pop.
Please check it out, and
here is the full experience,
I will see you tomorrow,
it's tomorrow at 10 a.m?
- I thought it was nine still but--
- Tomorrow is 10 a.m
because one of us is sharp
and the other is not.
- No, I'm not sharp.
- Check this.
I am giving away the
ultimate GaryVee experience.
How should I go?
Okay.
Over the last week or so I've been jamming
with my friend Michael
Rubin and helping out
on this all-in challenge
that I am accepting right now
but allinchallenge.com please go there,
we are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world,
to provide a ridiculous
all time experience
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection,
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time.
So now I have to put up my auction,
so my auction the ultimate
GaryVee experience here we go.
I'm gonna go off the top of the head.
And you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this,
I am giving away okay, you
get to in the corse of a year,
you will go garage sailing
with me and film "Trash Talk."
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti,
so I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also, we're going to go to Wine Library
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna pay my dad.
Well, I'm gonna donate,
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000
so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories,
and you'll buy a bunch
of a wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me,
I never do this, when I
give away Jets tickets,
I never let the person sit with me,
so you will sit with me
during the Jets game,
I won't talk to you during the game,
I'm completely focused
but you'll get that,
so the ultimate Jets experience,
tailgate full game with me as well.
Also, I'm going to give you
one week play at VaynerMedia,
so this is for you and
a plus one by the way.
So the two tickets,
we'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and
you depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting
and business advice
from TeamGaryVee and me
for the entire week hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest of my podcast,
we're gonna do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends
at Hunt & Fish Club
in New York City,
and I'm gonna fly you, all paid, plus one,
to three of my keynotes, and
we'll work on those details.
The ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it,
I hope you get involved,
I hope we raised a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also what's so fun about
the All-In Challenge is,
you get to challenge people to be in it.
I'm gonna challenge all
the VaynerSports athletes,
I expect you in there,
so that is number one.
Number two, I'm gonna go
with oh, you know what?
Timbaland, the super producer
who's completely lighting up
Instagram, Timbaland, the super producer,
I'm calling you out.
And finally I got one.
The Undertaker, one of the
great wrestlers of all time.
Please join the challenge,
everybody go to allinchallenge.com,
please support this, the
experiences are gonna be nuts.
We've been working,
bleeding out of the eyeballs
for the last week putting
this all together,
you're gonna be blown
away what you're about
to see on social media,
#allinchallenge.
Please check it out
and please go to your
favorite celebrities,
athletes and entertainers,
and leave hashtag All-In
Challenge to get them involved.
The All-In Challenge, please take it.